SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GIL. ARCHULETTA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER,
SHAKESPEARE. BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. ORTEZ E. DELI. DODD.
HUESO. HAGMAN. GLASER. GONZALES.
GROVE. TODD Ó. JONES. LAYERED
LEMON. MCGUIRE MENJIVAR. MEN.
NEWMAN. WHEN NILO. OR CHILD BUG
BY THE PORTANTINO BROTH. RUBIO.
SUHARTO SKINNER. SMALLER
QUIVERS. STERN. NUMBER AHA!
WIENER. WELCOME. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WHERE THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY, PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON
BY OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER, MICHELE
GORMAN, AFTER WHICH POLICE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. TODAY WE
PRAY FOR GOD'S MERCY FOR ALL OF
US. IF WE UTTER THE WORD MERCY
STANDING EACH OF US BY AN OPEN
WINDOW. ANYWHERE WE ARE IN THE
WORLD. THEN THE WORD MERCY WILL
CARRY AND THE SOUND WAVES.
ONWARDS AND UNCEASING. THROUGH
THE AIR OF THE WOUNDED WORLD.
AND MAYBE WHEN IT TAKES FLIGHT.
INTO DEED AND KINDNESS, JUSTICE
AND EFFORT. AS WELL AFFECT A
HEALING HOPE AND A BLESSING. IT
MAY CALL THE HOMELESS HOME. IT
MAY COKES TO HOPE THAT BETRAYED
AND BROKEN. IT MAY EASE THE
BURDEN EARTH. LISTEN FOR IT.
LISTEN FOR ITS NEIGHBORLY
DIALECTS AND GLOBAL IDIOM.
IMAGINE THOSE WHO LIKE YOU ARE
SAYING IT ALOUD. AND THOSE WHO
NEED TO HEAR IT TODAY. ONE WORD.
ONE DUDE OF JUSTICE. ONE KIND
EFFORT AT A TIME. GRACIOUS GOD.
WE ASK YOU TO GIVE US THE
COURAGE TO SAY AND BE MERCY
TODAY. MOST ESPECIALLY TO
OURSELVES. AMEN. PLEASE REPEAT
AFTER ME. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THAT LOOKS GOOD. OKAY, I KNOW
NOW FROM SCHOOL. PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
TO ITEM FOR MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR, GOVERNOR AND THAT WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
. REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. NOW MOVING TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. IF I'M
NOT HAVING FUN, YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO HAVE FUN ON WHO THAT
WAS LAUGHING, BUT I DON'T LIKE
IT. ALRIGHT MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION, JOINT RULE 62 A WILL
BE WAIVED FOR THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO MEET ON THURSDAY.
JANUARY 18TH 2024 WITHOUT TWO
DAYS NOTICED IN THE DAILY FILE.
SENATOR GROVER. I SEE THAT YOU
HAVE YOUR MIKE UP. YEAH. I AM
PREPARED FOR YOU TO CALL ON ME
FOR GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS, BUT
I WILL WAIT PATIENTLY UNTIL YOU
DO, SIR. WELL, I LIKE YOUR
ENTHUSIASM. ALRIGHT NEXT. WE'RE
GOING TO INTRODUCTION OF FIRST
READING OF BILL'S SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ CENTER BILLS 9 29 9
3931. THANK YOU NOW MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
FIRST ITEM IS SECOND READING
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ CENTERVILLE 827.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW WE TURN
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. AND
SENATOR GROVE IS PREPARED. SO,
SECRETARY PLEASE READ OH, NO
READING FOR A FILE ITEM. 53 GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES WELCOME BACK. THIS IS
OUR FIRST GOVERNORS CONFIRMATION
ON THE FLOOR. IT'S AND IT'S AN
APPROPRIATE ONE TO BE THE FIRST
IT'S LINDSAY SIN FOR THE
APPOINTMENT OF SECRETARY OF
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS SECRETARY SIN
HAS WORKED MORE THAN 10 YEARS.
AT THE EXECUTIVE LEVEL OF CAL
VET AND MOST OF THAT TIME
SERVING AS A DEPUTY SECRETARY
FOR WOMEN VETERANS AFFAIRS. SHE
SERVED THE UNITED STATES NAVY
FROM 1997 TO 2005, AND SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JANUARY 10TH AND A UNANIMOUS
VOTE RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR YOUR
I VOTE, ALRIGHT, SAYING THAT
SENATOR ARCHULETTA. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT TO RISE AND
SUPPORT. OF UH, LINDSAY SIN, THE
SECRETARY OF CAL VET. ACTUALLY
IT'S WE HEARD SERVED. THE UNITED
STATES NAVY VETERAN SERVED WITH
HONOR AND DISTINCTION AND AS THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
COMMUNICATIONS FOR WOMEN AND CAL
VET, SHE DID AN OUTSTANDING JOB.
HMM AND I MET WITH HER SEVERAL
TIMES IN MY OFFICE AS HE WAS
TAKING OFFICE AND PREPARING AND
I FOUND HER TO BE DEDICATED,
COMPETENT AND PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS NEW POSITION. AND LINDSAY'S
MILITARY BACKGROUND. IF YOU
HEARD IS ONE OF THE BEST YOU CAN
FIND IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
UH SHE HAS ALSO DEDICATED HER
LIFE TO SERVING AND REPRESENTING
VETERANS, AND I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT, UH, AS THE FIRST WOMAN TO
SERVE IN THIS POSITION, SINCE
1975 WOULD BE AN HONOR TO HAVE
HER WITH US, AND I URGENTLY
SUPPORT HER APPOINTMENT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, SIR. SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT.
I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY SO WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
PICO RIVERA, I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH
SECRETARY SENT FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS. I'VE ALWAYS FOUND HER TO
BE THOUGHTFUL EXCESS A BLE AND I
KNOW THAT SHE IS VERY HIGHLY
REGARDED. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HER AND I URGE AND
I VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU, SIR.
SENATOR MENJIVAR. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AS A FEMALE
VETERAN, IT IS MY GREAT HONOR TO
ASK FOR AN EYE BOAT OF LINDSAY.
AS YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM PICO RIVERA. WE HAVEN'T HAD
A FEMALE LEAD THE CALVET IN 49
YEARS. INDIA'S WELL MORE THAN,
UM, QUALIFIED FOR THIS ROLE AT A
TIME WHERE THE GROWERS GROWING
THE NUMBER ONE GROWING
POPULATION VETERANS ARE FEMALE
VETERANS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE AMOUNT ONLY 10%
OF THE VETERAN POPULATION. I'M
SO HONORED TO HAVE US LEAD US
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS FOR MY VOTE THANK YOU,
SENATOR, SENATOR DODD. YES MR
PRESIDENT AS THE ONLY NON
VETERAN SPEAKING TODAY ON THE
FLOOR FOR SECRETARY THIN, UH, I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET HER
ONCE, UM, I HAVE THE VETERANS
HOME CALIFORNIA VETERANS HOME IN
YONVILLE, CALIFORNIA IN MY
DISTRICT AND THAT THAT AREA HAS
BEEN PLAYED WITH YOUR ISSUES
FROM TIME TO TIME. AND YOU KNOW,
SHE CAME TO MY OFFICE AND I WAS
IMMEDIATELY IMPRESSED. NOT ONLY
WITH THEIR QUALIFICATIONS, BUT
OUR WILLINGNESS TO KIND OF PEEL
BACK THE ENDING AND LOOK AT
OTHER THINGS. AND THEN, UH, SHE
PUT ON A COMMUNITY EVENT AT THE
VET'S HOME ABOUT THREE WEEKS AGO
THAT I THOUGHT WAS ABSOLUTELY
AMAZING HAS NOT HAPPENED,
PROBABLY A DECADE, SO I'M REALLY
HIGH ON HER AND WISH HER WELL
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
YES. THANK YOU, SENATOR DOT
CENTER GROVE. YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS. THANK YOU,
MR PRESIDENT. I CONCUR WITH WHAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE STATED OUT
ABOUT SECRETARY SIN. AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT, UM MY COLLEAGUE
FROM NAPA IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. I
DON'T THINK I'VE HAD ANYBODY
FROM THE SECRETARY OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS GO OUT TO THE BARSTOW
VETERANS HOME, AND SHE DID, AND
THE INDIVIDUALS IN THAT
COMMUNITY OR IN THAT IN THAT
VETERANS HOME, THE STAFF THE
VETERANS THEMSELVES WERE JUST
OVERJOYED THAT THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE VETERANS
ASSOCIATION HAD GONE. OUT TO
VISIT THEM AND SEE WHAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY FACING IN THAT DESERT
COMMUNITY, UM I KNOW THIS IS
KIND OF SILLY, BUT YOU KNOW, I
ASKED HER. SHE'S VERY DEDICATED
TO VETERANS VETERANS MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. SHE'S VERY
DEDICATED TO VETERANS HOUSING.
BUT I ASKED HER IF YOU WERE I
KNOW YOU HAVE A PROCESS YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH. BUT IF YOU WERE
QUEEN FOR A DAY WHAT YOU WOULD
YOU DO AN INSTANTLY, SHE SAID. I
WOULD ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES FOR ALL OF OUR VETERANS
THAT THEY'RE FACING AND
ERADICATE VETERANS. HOMELESSNESS
WOULD BE THE FIRST TOP TWO
THINGS AND I THINK THAT SPEAKS
VOLUMES FOR WHO SHE IS, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EITHER.
THANK YOU. SENATOR GRUB WITH
THAT SECRETARY CALLED THE ROLE
ALAN ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A GIRL.
ALRIGHT ARCHULETTA, RIGHT,
ASHBY. ATKINS. I BECKER
BLAKESPEAR ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
AYE, CABALLERO. ALRIGHT,
CORTESI. ALRIGHT, DOLLY!
ALRIGHT, DODD. ALRIGHT DURAZO.
AYE, EGGMAN. I GLASER I GONZALES
ALRIGHT, GROVE. ALRIGHT, SO.
ALRIGHT JONES. I LAIRD I LEMON.
MCGUIRE ALRIGHT MENU BAR.
ALRIGHT MEN. I NEWMAN I WHEN I
KNEEL Ó. CHILD BUG. HI.
PORTANTINO I ROSS. AYE, RUBIO.
SO YOU ARE AYE, SKINNER. AYE,
SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. I AM
BERG. I WILL HAVE AYE, WIENER. I
WELCOME HI. I CENTER GROVE MOVES
THE CALL THAT WILL MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM. 56 CENTER GROVE.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT,
COLLEAGUES FILE ITEM 56 IS A
CONFIRMATION OF CHIP ROBERSON,
UM, FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
COLLEGE SCHOOL OF LAW IN SAN
FRANCISCO. MR. ROBERTSON IS AN
ATTORNEY AND CO MANAGING PARTNER
WITH THE COMMERCIAL INDUSTRY
INDUSTRIAL PROPERTY COMPANY. HE
IS THE ALUMNI OF THE LAW SCHOOL
AND HAS SERVED ON THE BOARD
SINCE 2011. HE WAS FORMALLY
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON A 50 VOTE, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR GROVE NOTE SAYING NO
MICROPHONES UP, SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ALRIGHT I BROUGHT A GILL I
ARCHULETTA ALRIGHT, ASHBY.
ATKINS. I BECKER BLAKESPEAR AYE,
BRADFORD. AYE, CABALLERO. AYE,
CORTESI. I DOLLY. AYE, DODD. I
DO THAT SO I ADMIN. AYE, GLASER.
ALRIGHT GONZALES. ALL RIGHT,
GIRLS. I TODDLE. AYE JONES. I
LAIRD I LEMON? MCGUIRE AYE,
MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT MEN. I NEWMAN
I WHEN ALRIGHT, NILO. WATCH OUR
BUG. I IDEA. ALRIGHT,
PORTANTINO. ALRIGHT, ROTH. AYE,
RUBIO. SEYARTO ALRIGHT SKINNER.
ALRIGHT, SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE,
STERN. I AM BERG. I WILL HAVE.
AYE WIENER. I WELCOME HI. CENTER
GROVE MOVES THE CALL. NOW WE'LL
MOVE ON TO SENATE THIRD READING
FILE ITEMS 63. SECRETARY. PLEASE
READ SENATOR MEN. ARE YOU READY?
SECRETARY. PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION 51 BY SENATOR MEN
RELATIVE TO KOREAN AMERICAN DAY,
SENATOR MAN FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR PRESIDENT AS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE ÁP LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND AS THE ONLY KOREAN
AMERICAN LEGISLATOR IN
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE,
IT'S WITH GREAT PLEASURE THAT I
PRESENT S R 51, WHICH PROCLAIMS
JANUARY 13TH 2024. AS KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY AND MARKS THE 121ST
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FIRST KOREAN
IMMIGRANTS REACHING THE SHORE OF
THE UNITED STATES AND ALSO
CELEBRATES A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF KOREAN
AMERICANS TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOW I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING THE SECOND
EVER. KOREAN AMERICAN TO SERVE
IN THE STATE SENATE, THE FIRST
ALFRED SONG, WHO WAS ELECTED IN
1961 1ST TO THE ASSEMBLY AND
THEN LATER TO THE SENATE, WAS
THE FIRST EVER ASIAN AMERICAN TO
SERVE IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE. WE'VE MADE GREAT
STRIDES SINCE THEN. TODAY MORE
THAN 800,000. KOREAN AMERICANS
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME CONTINUING
TO ADD TO THE VIBRANT FABRIC OF
OUR DIVERSE SOCIETY AND FEELS
LIKE STEM THE LAW, EDUCATION,
ENTERTAINMENT AND SO MUCH MORE
MANY OF YOU MAY HAVE SEEN THAT
STEVEN YEUN WON A BEST ACTOR,
GOLDEN GLOBE, FIRST KOREAN
AMERICAN TO EVER WIN THAT AWARD,
AND I'LL JUST TELL YOU AS A
KOREAN AMERICAN GROWING UP IN
THIS STATE AT A TIME AND A PLACE
WHERE THERE WERE NOT ANY OTHER
KOREAN AMERICANS WHERE THERE ARE
REALLY ONLY JUST A HANDFUL OF
ASIAN AMERICANS. UM IT WAS A
DIFFERENT TIME AND I WILL ADMIT
THAT GROWING UP IN THE 19
EIGHTIES AND CALIFORNIA I WAS
OFTEN NOT PROUD TO BE A KOREAN
AMERICAN FOODS THAT MY PEOPLE
ARE KNOWN FOR THINGS LIKE KIMCHI
. WE'RE NOT SEEING AS UH, NORMAL
THEY WERE SEEN AS STINKY OR
YUCKY. AND SO IT'S BEEN GREAT
PRIDE THAT I'VE SEEN THE GREAT
STRIDES THAT KOREANS AND KOREAN
AMERICANS HAVE MADE OVER TIME,
THE POINT WHERE SOME OF THE MOST
POPULAR TELEVISION SHOWS SOME OF
THE MOST POPULAR MOVIES OUT
THERE. AH OUR KOREAN FEATURE
KOREAN AMERICAN ACTORS. THAT
MEANS A LOT TO ME TO SEE OUR
ELECTRONIC PRODUCTS. CARS
VIBRANT GLOBAL ECONOMY FROM
KOREA, A COUNTRY WHICH NOT SO
LONG AGO WAS WAR TORN AND
DEVASTATED AND STRUGGLING TO
JUST FEED ITS OWN PEOPLE. UH AND
TODAY I LOOK AROUND AND YOU
KNOW, I HAD THE PRIVILEGE LAST
YEAR OF CELEBRATING JIM CHEE DAY
AND GIVING KIMCHI TOO MANY OF
YOU. AND MANY OF YOU ACTUALLY
ATE IT, WHICH WAS A COOL THING.
UM BUT IT IS JUST A POINT OF
PRIDE TO ME TO SEE AS I'VE GROWN
OLDER. JUST HOW MY KIDS TODAY
CALLED KOREAN CULTURE. COOL AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT AS A
YOUNG KID IN CALIFORNIA I NEVER
COULD HAVE IMAGINED, AND THAT'S
A TESTAMENT TO WHAT CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA DREAM,
AND I WANT TO JUST HONOR THAT AS
WELL TODAY, SO LET'S RECOGNIZE
CALIFORNIA'S RICH CULTURAL
HISTORY. AND HONOR. THE IMMENSE
CONTRIBUTIONS AT KOREAN
AMERICANS HAVE MADE AND CONTINUE
TO MAKE FOR THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. MEN, SENATOR NEWMAN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS AND SUPPORTIVE S. R 51
THE KOREAN JEWISH EXPERIENCES,
AS WITH SO MANY IMMIGRANT
EXPERIENCES, SHARE SIMILARITIES,
INCLUDING THE OBVIOUS RESIDENTS
IN THE SEEKING OF OPPORTUNITY
AND STABILITY IN AMERICA AND THE
SUBSEQUENT ENERGETIC PURSUIT OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM. THE AMERICAN
, KOREAN AND JEWISH COMMUNITIES
BOTH COUNT CALIFORNIA. IS AMONG
THE LARGEST DIASPORAS. TODAY'S
RESOLUTION POINTS TO AND
CELEBRATE THE INTENTIONAL
HISTORICAL EXPERIENCE OF
EMBRACING A NEW HOME WHILE
CONCURRENTLY PRESERVING AND
FINDING JOY IN THE ROOTS AND
TRADITIONS BROUGHT WITH THEM TO
AMERICA AND ESSENTIAL IMPULSE
THAT IS COMMON TO MANY CULTURES
AS THE RESOLUTION BEFORE US
APPROPRIATELY, ACKNOWLEDGES,
KOREAN AMERICANS HAVE BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT OF THE GROWING
INFLUENCE AND POWER OF KOREAN
CULTURE. IN RECENT YEARS. KOREAN
EXPORTS BOTH COMMERCIAL AND
CULTURAL, HAVE ACHIEVED AN
IMPRESSIVE PROMINENCE IN THE
LIVES OF SO MANY CALIFORNIANS IN
MY OWN DISTRICT, THE CITY OF
BUENA PARK RECENTLY DESIGNATED
SECTION OF THAT CITY AS KOREA
TOÀN, WHICH NOW GIVES.
ORANGE-COUNTY-REGISTER-TOO-SOON-COUNTY-VOTE-CENTERS
CELEBRATE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
THE KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES.
MY SEAT MATE, AND I BOTH HAVE
VERY POSITIVE MEMORIES OF
SERVING IN THE UNITED STATES
ARMY IN THE REPUBLICAN SOUTH
KOREA. IT IS MY PLEASURE, AND IT
IS A PLEASURE OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS TO
CELEBRATE THE KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY AND WE URGE YOUR I
VOTE TODAY ON S R 51. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATOR DURAZO.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AND
ALSO REPRESENTING, UM, MY
DISTRICT OF SD 26 BECAUSE OF THE
PRESENCE OF THE KOREAN COMMUNITY
. I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT WHEN
THE LARGEST KOREAN COMMUNITIES
IN THE COUNTRY WHOSE HISTORY AND
CULTURE AH DISTRICT ENRICH
CALIFORNIA, LOS ANGELES AND ALL
OF CALIFORNIA FOOD MUSIC, DANCE
BUSINESSES AND LABOR. PROMINENT
ACTIVIST DAWSON CHANG HO AND
IMMIGRATED TO THE US AND SETTLED
IN RIVERSIDE, WHICH WAS KNOWN
FOR ITS BOOMING CITY CITRUSY
INDUSTRY. BUT IN 1905, HE FORMED
THE PETAPA CAMP IN RIVERSIDE,
THE FIRST KOREATOWN DISTRICT IN
THE NATION. ALTHOUGH PETAPA CAMP
LASTED ONLY 15 YEARS, IT WAS
CONSIDERED THE LARGEST CENTRAL
POINT FOR THE KOREAN COMMUNITY
ON AND HIS FAMILY MOVED TO LOS
ANGELES AND SETTLED ON BUNKER
HILL IN THE CENTER OF DOWNTOWN
HE FOUNDED THE KOREAN UNITED
PRESBYTERIAN CHURCH, AND I
BECAME A CENTRALIZED LOCATION
FOR THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY AND
GRADUALLY BECAME THE KOREATOWN
DISTRICT. ANOTHER VISIONARY WAS
KOREAN IMMIGRANT. UH HE DUKE LI
LI IMMIGRATED TO THE LOS ANGELES
IN 1968 AND CREATED SPACE FOR
THE KOREAN COMMUNITY. HE OPENED
THE OLYMPIC MARKET AND BECAME A
PRIMARY DESTINATION FOR
THOUSANDS OF KOREANS LIVING IN
LOS ANGELES. THIS WAS THE FIRST
KOREAN DRIVEN MARKET IN, UH 1971
1980. KOREATOWN WAS RECOGNIZED
AND DECLARED AN OFFICIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY NOW IS ONE OF OUR
COUNTRY'S MOST DIVERSE AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL, BOOMING
CULINARY COMMUNITIES. THE V I. P
PALACE WAS THE FIRST BUILDING IN
LOS ANGELES TO FEATURE
TRADITIONAL KOREAN TILES, THEIR
ORIGINAL ARCHITECT, A V I, P
PALACE REMAINS KOREAN AMERICAN
DAY ALLOWS US TO HONOR THE GREAT
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR KOREAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. PLACES LIKE
KOREA TOWN HAVE GRANTED A HOME
TO MANY DIVERSE COMMUNITIES,
INCLUDING THE LATINO COMMUNITY,
WHERE MANY SMALL BUSINESSES SUCH
AS RESTAURANTS, BARS AND CAFES
CAN BE FOUND. THERE'S A HISTORIC
AND CULTURAL HOME FOR OUR
RESIDENTS. WHO FOUGHT TO
PRESERVE AND PROTECT THEIR
COMMUNITY. IT WEIGHS HIS
TREMENDOUS HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE, BUT OF ALL ABOVE
ALL INCLUSIVITY AND DIVERSITY,
BRIDGING KOREAN AND LATINOS
SIMILARITIES OF OUR IMMIGRANT
EXPERIENCE FOR A BETTER LIFE.
LET US HONOR NOT JUST THE
HISTORY OF KOREAN AMERICANS,
KOREAN AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT THE RICH
EXPERIENCES THEY BRING THE
IMPACT THAT THE KOREAN COMMUNITY
HAS HAD ON OUR COUNTRY FOR 121
YEARS. IT HAS TRANSCENDED
CULTURES, COMMUNITIES AND
ECONOMIES. FOR THIS REASON, I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE ON S R 51.
THANK YOU, SENATOR RAZO, SENATOR
PADILLA. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT
. I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LGBTQ CAUCUS AND
SUPPORT S R 51 RECOGNIZING
JANUARY 13TH IS KOREAN AMERICAN
DAY THIS PAST SATURDAY MARKED
THE 121ST ANNIVERSARY OF THE
HISTORIC 102 KOREANS WHO
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
IN SEARCH OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEMSELVES AND FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. IN THE YEARS SINCE
KOREAN AMERICANS HAVE GREATLY
ENRICHED OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
OUR NATION'S CULTURE AND
SOCIETY. CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
ONE OF THE LARGEST POPULATIONS
OF KOREAN AMERICANS, AND THE
SUCCESS OF THE STATE IS DUE IN
PART TO THEIR INVALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO THE INVALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE KOREAN
COMMUNITY. I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO HONOR UH TO HIGHLIGHT
A FEW OF THE INCREDIBLE LGBTQ
KOREAN AMERICAN TRAILBLAZERS.
MARGARET SHOW YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
OF IS A QUEER KOREAN AMERICAN
COMEDIAN, ACTRESS, AUTHOR,
MUSICIAN AND ACTIVIST. AFTER
MARRIAGE EQUALITY FIRST BECAME
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA IN 2008, SHE
WAS DEPUTIZED TO OFFICIATE SAME
SEX MARRIAGES. SHE HAS ALSO BEEN
A LONGTIME ADVOCATE. GET FOR
ANTI RACISM AND ANTI BULLYING AS
WELL AS A VOCAL ACTIVISTS FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ON HOUSED HAYDEN
ROYALTY IS A QUEER GENDER QUEER
CALIFORNIAN WHO LAUNCHED A
YOUTUBE CHANNEL TO ADD THEIR
DIVERSE, NON BINARY COMMUNITY.
KOREAN AMERICAN REPRESENTATION
IN CONTENT CREATION. THEY
CURRENTLY TEACH STUDENTS IN
KOREA AND PLAN TO EVENTUALLY
MOVE TO PURSUE A CAREER IN
SOCIAL WORK. TO INCREASE THE
REPRESENTATION OF QUEER AND
ASIAN COUNSELORS AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST. EUGENE LEE YANG IS AN
ACTOR, WRITER DIRECTOR AND ONE
OF TODAY'S MOST RECOGNIZABLE
QUEER ASIAN AMERICAN PERFORMERS.
HE HAS HIS WRITING AND
DIRECTORIAL DEBUT IN DEVELOPMENT
, A Y, A FANTASY NEIDL NOVEL
TITLED THE UNDERS AND A GRAPHIC
NOVEL IN DEVELOPMENT CALLED
BUCKAROO. THESE ARE BUT A FEW OF
THE INCREDIBLE TRAILBLAZERS WHO
HAVE USED THEIR
INTERSECTIONALITY IS A TOOL TO
DEMONSTRATE THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT THE KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HAVE ADDED TO OUR RICH
CULTURAL DIVERSITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD LIKE TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE FOR
BRINGING FORTH THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU, SIR.
NEXT SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SHARING THIS THIS
CELEBRATION OF KOREAN CULTURE
HERE IN THE CHAMBER I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF S, R 51 AND
RECOGNITION OF KOREAN AMERICAN
DAY TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE ENDURING
CONTRIBUTIONS, RESILIENCE AND
RICH CULTURAL DIVERSITY. KOREAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, AND I'M PROUD THAT
KOREATOWN A GOOD PORTION OF
KOREATOWN IS IN MY DISTRICT AND
WHERE L. A COUNTY HOLDS THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF A KOREAN
AH KOREANS OUTSIDE OF ASIA WITH
220,000. RESIDENTS OF OUR GREAT
COUNTY, HAILING FROM THIS RICH
CULTURE. MUCH OF THIS GROWTH AS
A RESULT OF THE HEART CELLAR ACT
PASSED IN 1965, WHICH WAS PART
OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS WAY THAT
GREATLY ALTERED US IMMIGRATION
POLICIES TO BE IN FAVOR OF
WELCOMING IMMIGRANTS FROM ASIA
AND OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD AS
A RESULT OF THAT, KOREAN
IMMIGRANTS, LIKE BLACK AMERICANS
HAVE ALWAYS STRUGGLED TO ENDURE
AGAINST ENORMOUS PLIGHTS OF
RACISM AND DISCRIMINATION. BUT
FOUND RESILIENCE AND POWER AND
CULTURE TO TELL THEIR STORIES
AND TO ALTER THE FABRIC OF OUR
COMMUNITIES, AND PARTICULARLY
HERE IN THE STATE TO UNDERSTAND
WHY FREEDOM IS IMPORTANT FOR ALL
OF US UNDER THE BANNER OF THE
AMERICAN FLAG, THEY HAVE ALSO
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR CIVIL AND
HUMAN RIGHTS MOVEMENT
DOMESTICALLY AND ABROAD,
FOSTERING. PEACE AROUND THE
WORLD BY THE 19 SEVENTIES,
KOREAN IMMIGRANTS SOUGHT TO
ESTABLISH A MAJOR CULTURAL AND
ECONOMIC PRESENT IN LOS ANGELES,
TURNING OLYMPIC BOULEVARD NEAR
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES INTO WHAT
WE NOW CALL KOREATOWN BASED IN
THE HEART OF MY DISTRICT, AS I
MENTIONED, AND IT IS FILLED WITH
OVER 5000 BUSINESSES. 500
RESTAURANTS, BECOMING ONE OF THE
MOST ROBUST ECONOMIC ENGINES IN
OUR GREAT CITY, KOREA TOWN IS
ALSO HOME TO A NUMBER OF
ADVOCACY GROUPS AND LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING THE
KOREAN IMMIGRANT WORKERS
ALLIANCE, KNOWN AS KIWA THAT
CONTINUES TO FIGHT AND ADVOCATE
FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS, ENSURING
THAT ALL WORKERS HAVE FAIR AND
EQUITABLE PAY AND OPPORTUNITIES.
IN OUR GREAT STATE. EACH YEAR,
KOREATOWN HOSTS THE LOS ANGELES
KOREA FESTIVAL, WHICH WE WERE
HAPPY TO CELEBRATE 50 YEARS OF
THIS FOUR DAY EVENT AND TO
CELEBRATE WITH KOREAN LEADERS
FROM ACROSS THAT GREAT COUNTRY
AND MAKING SURE THAT COMMUNITIES
BOTH AT HOME AND ABROAD ARE
CARED FOR AND WELL REPRESENTED.
KOREATOWN SYMBOLIZES HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR CULTURAL
DISTRICTS TO PROSPER. AND IT
SERVES AS A BEACON OF HOPE AND
OPPORTUNITY NOT JUST FOR KOREAN
AMERICANS, BUT ALL REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES TO COME TOGETHER,
CELEBRATE EACH OTHER AND TO
BUILD A CLOTH UNITED OF CULTURE,
DIVERSITY AND COMMUNITY VOICE
LIKE SO MANY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR IN OUR STATE, ASIAN
COMMUNITIES ARE ARE NOT
PROTECTED AGAINST HATE CRIMES,
AND WE SAW SOME OF THE
VICIOUSNESS OF THAT DURING OUR
COVID EXPERIENCE, BUT KOREAN
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ALONG WITH
OTHERS TOGETHER AGAINST HATE,
AND TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WERE PROTECTED IN
PLACES WHERE THEY WORK, WHERE
THEY GO TO SCHOOL AND WHERE THEY
LIVE. WHILE HISTORIC POLICIES
HAVE PITTED COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
AGAINST ONE ANOTHER. TO COMPETE
FOR LIMITED RESOURCES. SO PROUD
THAT KOREATOWN, ALONG WITH
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES CONTINUE
TO STAND TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT
INCREASING NEEDS ARE MET WITH
INCREASING RESOURCES IN A
SOLIDARITY OF BELOVED COMMUNITY.
LET US CONTINUE TO BUILD BRIDGES
FIND WAYS TO SUPPORT ONE ANOTHER
AND TO ENSURE THAT WE CELEBRATE
KOREAN AMERICAN DAY THIS YEAR.
COMMITTED TO THE CLOTH OF UNITY
AND STANDING STRONG FOR FREEDOM
AND JUSTICE. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY CALL FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
HAMBURG. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT, COLLEAGUES. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE HUGE NUMBER OF
KOREAN AMERICANS THAT I
REPRESENT WHEN I BEGAN MY
LEGISLATIVE CAREER GARDEN GROVE
IS AT THE HEART OF THE DISTRICT
IN THE HEART OF GARDEN GROVE WAS
KOREATOWN AND NOW I'M BLESSED TO
REPRESENT BOTH GARDEN GROVE AND
KOREA TOWN AND GARDEN GROVE AS
WELL AS KOREATOWN IN BUENA PARK.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, UM I AM
GRATEFUL TO THE REPUBLIC OF
KOREA AND I RISE ON BEHALF OF MY
THREE CHILDREN AND SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN, BUT FOR THE
UNITED STATES ARMY AND THE
REPUBLIC OF KOREA, THEY WOULDN'T
BE HERE I URGE AND I VOTE. THANK
YOU, SENATOR HAMBURG. SEEING I
KNOW OTHER MIX UP CENTER MEN.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL REMARKS AND GREAT TO
FEEL THE LOVE AND JUST WANTED TO
REFLECT ON THE APPROPRIATENESS
OF THIS VOTE BEING TAKEN UP THE
DAY AFTER MARTIN LUTHER KING DAY
, AS I THINK WAS ALLUDED TO THE
L. A RIOTS WERE A TRAUMATIC
EVENT IN RACE RELATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT I THINK THAT'S
ALSO A TEACHABLE MOMENT BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT THE KOREAN AND BLACK
COMMUNITIES WORKED REALLY HARD
AT AFTER THAT DAY IN 1992. TO
TRY TO BUILD LASTING BRIDGES,
AND IT'S A REMINDER TO US THAT
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE WORKING HARD
TO BUILD THE SOCIETY THAT WE
WANT TO SEE A SOCIETY WHERE
DIVERSITY AND COEXISTENCE AND
INCLUSION ARE VALUED. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH URGE, AND I VOTE
AND I GUESS I JUST CLOSE BY
SAYING IF YOU WANT TO CELEBRATE,
GO OUT AND EAT SOME KOREAN
BARBECUE OR IF YOU'RE A
VEGETARIAN EATS SOME SUN DO
BOOST THEM TOFU SOUP. LISTEN TO
SOME K POP OR WATCH THEM. KOREAN
DRAMA OR BEEF AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH ADD RESPECTFULLY ASKED YOUR
I VOTE. THANK YOU, SIR. MIN.
WITH THAT SECRETARY CALLED THE
ROLE ALAN ALRIGHT. I BROUGHT A
GIRL. ALRIGHT ARCHULETTA.
ALRIGHT ASHBY. ATKINS. I BECKER
BLAKESPEAR ALRIGHT, BRADFORD.
AYE, CABALLERO. AYE, CORTEZ E.
ALRIGHT, DOLLY! DODD. I DO SO.
AYE EGGMAN. I GLASER. AYE.
GONZALES. I GIRL AYE. TODD. OH,
I JONES AYE, LAIRD. I LEMON?
MCGUIRE I MENJIVAR. ALRIGHT MAN,
I NEWMAN I WHEN I NEED ALOT. BUT
YOUR BOOK AYE. PORTANTINO
ALRIGHT, WRATH. AYE, RUBIO.
ALRIGHT, SO YOUR TOE AYE,
SKINNER. AYE SMALLWOOD QUIVERS.
AYE, STERN. I AM BERG, I HA! AYE
WIENER. AYE, WILK. AYE. CULTURE
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY.
BECKER. DELI. LEMON. HELLO.
CALLED THE ABSOLUTE MEMBERS ONE
FINAL TIME. ASHBY. BECKER.
DOLLY! ALL RIGHT. LEMON. HELLO.
36 NO. ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE, MEMBERS. WE'RE GONNA
GO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THEN
AFTER THAT WE'RE GONNA NOW THAT
WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE WILL GO
BACK TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
WITH THAT CONSENT CALENDAR. FILE
ITEMS 67 AT THIS POINT IN TIME,
WOULD ANYBODY CARE TO PULL THE
ITEM ARTHUR CONSENT CALENDAR.
THING NONE. SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL. PLEASE READ. I'M SORRY.
SENATE BILL 251. OKAY, NOW YOU
CAN CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU.
ALAN. I BROUGHT A GILL. ALRIGHT
ARCHULETTA. AYE, ASHBY. ATKINS.
HI, BECKER. BLAKESPEAR ALRIGHT,
BRADFORD. ALRIGHT, CABALLERO. HI
CORTEZ E. I DOLLY. AYE, DODD. I
DO THAT? SO I EGGMAN AYE,
GLASER. AYE. GONZALES. AYE,
GROVE. AYE. AYE JONES. I LAIRD I
LEMON? MCGUIRE I MENJIVAR. ALL
RIGHT, MAN. AYE NEWMAN. I WHEN
ALRIGHT, NILO. WHAT'S YOUR BOOK?
ALRIGHT, BADIA. HI, PORTANTINO.
HI, ROD. AYE, RUBIO. ALRIGHT
SUHARTO. AYE, SKINNER. ALRIGHT,
SMALLER CUEVAS. AYE, STERN. I
REMEMBER. I WOULD HAVE AYE,
WIENER. AYE, WILK. AYE. 36 NO.
ZERO CASSETTE CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. NOW MEMBERS WERE GOING
BACK TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
FILE ITEMS 53 SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY.
BECKER. LEMON. HELLO. RUBIO.
AYE. IT IS 36 NO. ZERO THE
GOVERNMENT'S APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM OF 56. SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY.
BECKER. LEMON. NILO. RUBIO? AYE.
IT IS 36 AND ZERO GOVERNMENT
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. NOW MOVING. ACTUALLY,
WE'RE TURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND THIS IS
APPROPRIATE TIME TO DO A JOURNEY
IN MEMORIES. AND OUR FIRST
PRESENTER IS THE PRO TEMP
SENATOR ATKINS ON BEHALF OF
WILLIAM PATRICK CREW ERROR. PRO
TAN FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A TRUE
CIVIC LEADER. WILLIAM PATRICK,
PAT CREW, OUR AS WE KNEW HIM,
PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER 1ST
AFTER A VERY LONG BATTLE WITH
PARKINSON'S DISEASE. PAT WAS
KNOWN FOR HIS CHARISMA, HIS BIG
HEART, HIS INCREDIBLE SENSE OF
HUMOR. HE WAS A LOYAL FRIEND,
VERY SMART DRESSER AND A LOVER
OF FAST CARS. FOR DECADES. PAT
WAS A CRITICAL FORCE FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN THE SAN DIEGO
REGION AND IN THE WESTERN UNITED
STATES. HE HAD A LONG AND
DISTINGUISHED CAREER IN REAL
ESTATE DEVELOPMENT AND WAS
HIGHLY RESPECTED FOR HIS
COMMITMENT TO BUILDING BRIDGES
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AND THE REAL
ESTATE INDUSTRY. THAT WAS BORN
IN HEART, MICHIGAN ON MARCH 3RD
1945 AND CAME TO SAN DIEGO WHEN
HE SERVED WITH THE UNITED STATES
NAVY DURING THE VIETNAM WAR. HE
WAS A PROUD SAN DIEGAN AND
SERVED ON NUMEROUS BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS TO GIVE BACK TO THE
CITY. HE LOVES SO MUCH. HE
SERVED AS A COMMISSIONER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION
FOR OVER A DECADE. HE WAS FIRST
APPOINTED BY CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER ANTONIO
VILLARAIGOSA IN 1999, AND HE WAS
REAPPOINTED THREE TIMES ABOUT
SUCCEEDING SPEAKERS. PAT WAS THE
FIRST HOUSING DEVELOPED BIRTH TO
BE ELECTED CHAIRMAN BY HIS
FELLOW COMMISSIONERS OF POSITION
THAT HE HELD FROM 2006 TO 2008.
IN THE 19 SEVENTIES AND EIGHTIES
PET SERVED ON THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY AND HIS
VICE CHAIRMAN AND CHAIRMAN OF
ITS LENDING COMMITTEE. HE WAS A
DIRECTOR OF THE FEDERAL HOME
LOAN BANK OF SAN FRANCISCO. HE
WAS FIRST APPOINTED UNDER
PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER IN 1981
AND THEN RE APPOINTED UNDER
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN. HE
SERVED ON THE FEDERAL SAVINGS
AND LOAN ADVISORY COUNCIL. PAT
WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF OUR
VERY FIRST HOUSING COMMISSION
FOR THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO IN
1979, THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
SELECTED HIM TO SERVICE THE
FIRST CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSING
BOND FINANCE REVIEW COMMITTEE
AND THE 919 EIGHTIES, AND HE WAS
ALSO THE FIRST CHAIRMAN OF THE
REGIONAL GROWTH AND PLANNING
REVIEW TASK FORCE FOR THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO. UM PAT. IS
SURVIVED BY HIS TWO DAUGHTERS,
SARA AND RACHEL. FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN. AND I LIKE TO
THINK THAT WAS A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF WOMEN. HE DIDN'T
JUST TALK IT. HE PROVED IT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN, AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY HIS DAUGHTERS ARE SO
STRONG IN CHARACTER AND
INTEGRITY IN THE WORK THAT THEY
DO. ONE FOLLOWED AND IS NOW THE
HEAD OF THE BUSINESS THAT HE RAN
FOR DECADES. HIS OTHER DAUGHTER,
A SCHOOLTEACHER. UM HIS FORMER
WIFE AND INCREDIBLY STRONG
PERSON. BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING,
JENNIFER AND I WILL MISS HIM. I
WILL A PERSONAL STORY. I
REMEMBER BEING AT AN EVENT A BIG
EVENT WITH A LOT OF VERY
IMPORTANT PEOPLE AND SOMEONE
WALKED UP TO MY SPOUSE AND ASK
HER IF SHE WORKED OUTSIDE THE
HOME. AT WHICH POINT I MOVED
AWAY AS FAR AS I COULD. AND THEN
I WATCHED THE TWINKLE IMPACTS I
AS HE PROCEEDED TO. IT WAS
AMAZING TO US GIVE THE PERSON
JENNIFER'S ENTIRE RESUME. AND
THEREAFTER. I THINK, UH, YOU
KNOW IT WAS. IT WAS REALLY
WONDERFUL TO HAVE HIM THERE
BECAUSE HE HAD A SENSE OF HUMOR,
AND HE COULD DO IT WITHOUT
REALLY UPSETTING PEOPLE. HE
BUILT BRIDGES. HE WAS INCREDIBLY
GOOD AT THAT. AND SO HE IS GOING
TO BE TRULY MISSED NOT ONLY BY
HIS INCREDIBLE FAMILY BUT BY A
COMMUNITY WHO WITNESSED THE WORK
THAT HE DID FOR DECADES AND HOW
HE BROUGHT PEOPLE TOGETHER TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS. AND, UM I
CERTAINLY EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE
FOR PAT'S DEDICATION ON BEHALF
OF THE SENATE WILL DO SO AT HIS
SERVICE ON SATURDAY AFTERNOON IN
SAN DIEGO. UM HE HAD A PASSION
FOR HOUSING, AND HE WILL BE
REMEMBERED VERY FONDLY IN SAN
DIEGO. SO I ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF PAT
CREW ARE TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT SENATOR CORTEZ E.
THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT. RISE TO
A JOURNEY. MEMORY OF MICHAEL E.
FOX A MAN OF MANY ROLES,
INCLUDING FATHER HUSBAND,
BUSINESSMAN AND PHILANTHROPIST.
HE WAS A POWERFUL FORCE IN
SILICON VALLEY. HE PASSED ON
NOVEMBER 3RD AT THE AGE OF 87.
IN 1965. MICHAEL ALONG WITH HIS
FAMILY FOUNDED EMMY, FOX AND
COMPANY. THIS ENDEAVOR GREW TO
BECOME ONE OF THE COUNTY'S
LARGEST BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS.
HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS ABILITY TO
GET THINGS DONE BEING DESCRIBED
AS SOMEONE SKILLED AT BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS AND BRINGING THE
RIGHT PEOPLE TOGETHER. TO SOLVE
DIFFICULT ISSUES. HIS JESUIT
EDUCATION AND CATHOLIC FAITH
WERE INTEGRAL TO HIS WORK HIS
ADVOCACY FOR THE SAFETY OF
CHILDREN WITHIN THE CHURCH
POLICY CHANGE AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL THROUGH THE CONFERENCE OF
CATHOLIC BISHOPS. HIS PASSION
FOR EDUCATION LED HIM TO CHEER
THE BOARD OF THE REGIONS OF
SANTA CLARA UNIVERSITY. HE WAS A
FOUNDER. OF THE VALLEY MEDICAL
CENTER FOUNDATION, CHAIRMAN OF
THE UNITED WAY OF SILICON
VALLEY. AND FOUNDING MEMBER OF
THE WEST VALLEY MISSION
FOUNDATION. MIKE LIVED AN
EXCITING LIFE. HE HOSTED MANY
PEOPLE IN HIS HOME, INCLUDING
FORMER PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER.
HIS THE FIRST LADY, OF COURSE.
ROSALYNN CARTER. FORMER
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS. HE ALSO
CARRIED THE OLYMPIC TORCH ON
THIS JOURNEY TO THE OLYMPICS. HE
LOVED HIS FAMILY DEEPLY AND MADE
SURE HIS CHILDREN UNDERSTOOD THE
FAMILY BUSINESS. HIS YOUNGEST
SON, TERRENCE. DESCRIBE DINNER
WITH HIS FATHER AS A LESSON IN
LIFE AND BUSINESS MANAGEMENT. HE
MADE SURE TO INCLUDE HIS FAMILY
AND CHARITABLE ENDEAVORS.
PASSING ALONG THE VALUE OF
SERVICE. IN FACT, IT GOES FAR AS
SAYING, MAKING IT MANDATORY
AMONGST HIS CHILDREN. HIS SON,
MIKE FOX JR. HAS BEEN A LIFELONG
FRIEND OF MINE IN A CONSTANT
SUPPORTER OF MY OWN ENDEAVORS.
AS HAS HAS BEEN HIS WIDOW, MARY
ELLEN. JUST TO SHARE A PERSONAL
REFLECTION. I GOT A CALL A FEW
YEARS BACK. FROM ARTURO
RODRIQUEZ, PRESIDENT, UNITED
FARM WORKERS. AND HE SAID HE
WANTED TO MEET. WE SAT DOWN AND
HE ASKED ME IF IT WAS POSSIBLE
POSSIBLE TO RAISE MONEY FOR A
NEW FARMWORKER CENTER, WHICH
WILL BE LOCATED IN SALINAS,
SILICON VALLEY. POSSIBLE TO
RAISE FUNDS UP AND SILICON
VALLEY BECAUSE THEY WERE FALLING
SHORT. IN PUTTING TOGETHER THE
CAPITAL CAMPAIGN FOR THE FARM
WORKER CENTER. I SAID, WELL,
FIRST OF ALL, STRATEGICALLY,
LET'S CHANGE THE NAME OF IT TO
THE CENTRAL COAST FARMWORKERS
CENTER. KIND OF SPREAD OUR WINGS
A LITTLE BIT, WHICH THERE ARE
MORE THAN WILLING TO DO IS THE
SECOND IF YOU COULD COME UP AND
MEET A COUPLE OF PEOPLE IN
SILICON VALLEY. TO HELP PRESS
THE CASE. I THINK WE CAN GET
THAT DONE. ONE OF THE FIRST
PERSONS I BROUGHT HIM TO WORDS.
MIKE FOX. AND OF COURSE, I
CALLED MIKE FIRST AND SAID
PRESIDENT UNITED FARM WORKERS
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN MEETING
WITH YOU. UH IF YOU HAVE ANY
INTEREST IN THAT WHATSOEVER I
FULLY EXPECTED THE ANSWER MIGHT
BE NO. UM, HE RESPONDED. YES YOU
KNOW, THERE'S LOTS OF THINGS I
WANT TO TALK TO HIM ABOUT. SO WE
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT ONCE
WE GOT THERE. IN MEETING WITH
MIKE. WAS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
GOING INTO THE PRO THAMES OFFICE
OR THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE. WHEN
YOU WENT INTO HIS HOUSE HE HAD
PURCHASED THE HOUSE IN SARATOGA
OF THE FORMER PUBLISHER OF THE
MERCURY NEWS, TONY RITTER, QUITE
AN ELEGANT PLACE AND WE SAT DOWN
WITH HIM. AND HE SAID, NOT ONLY
DO I WANT TO HELP AND TELL ME
HOW MUCH I CAN DO IN TERMS OF
WRITING A CHECK AND SUPPORTING
THE CAUSE. BUT LET'S HOLD A
FUNDRAISER RIGHT HERE AT MY
HOUSE. FOR THE FARM WORKERS. UM
AND WE DID THAT FUNDRAISER PUT
THE ENTIRE PROJECT OVER THE TOP.
AND IT JUST AN INDICATION OF THE
KIND OF HEART. UM THE MAN HAD
JUST AN INDICATION SO WHEN HE
SAID PHILANTHROPISTS WAS IT.
PHILANTHROPISTS IN THE SENSE OF,
YOU KNOW, SENDING A BIG CHECK TO
THE COMMUNITY FOUNDATION OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT? IT WAS THIS
KIND OF ON THE GROUND, ALMOST
GRASS TOPS GRASSROOTS OF
PHILANTHROPY THAT WE SEE IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT THERE
ARE A FEW PEOPLE WHO DO THAT.
AND I CAN CERTAINLY ATTEST TO UM
, THE PRESIDENTIAL VISITS THAT
HIS HOUSE I WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF
AN INTENSE CAMPAIGN. AND HE
INVITED MIKE AND MARY ELLEN
INVITED US TO HIS HOUSE. HE
SAID. YOU GOT TO BE THERE
BECAUSE JIMMY CARTER IS GOING TO
BE THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE
THERE. AND I WANT YOU TO MEET
HIM. SO WE SHOWED UP. AND OF
COURSE, THERE'S A GIGANTIC TENT
IN HIS YARD AND YOU KNOW, YOU
KIND OF WALK IN ASSUMING THAT UH
, YOU MIGHT HAVE A PHOTO OP OR A
HANDSHAKE AT SOME POINT WITH THE
PRESIDENT, AND THIS IS KIND OF
ONE OF THOSE EVENTS WHERE WHEN
YOU'RE BUSY, AND WHEN YOU'RE
RUNNING AND YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A CAMPAIGN, YOU MIGHT BE
THERE FOR A LITTLE WHILE AND
LEAVE. IN MY CAME OVER AND
GRABBED ME GRAB MY WIFE, PATTY.
AND HE SAID, COME WITH ME
BECAUSE I WANT TO PERSONALLY
SEAT YOU AND SEATED US RIGHT
NEXT TO THE PRESIDENT AND ROSE
ONE OF MY WIFE NEXT TO PRESIDENT
CARTER. AND SHE AND IF YOU KNEW
MY WIFE FULLY EXPECT FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN. UH LAUNCHED INTO ABOUT A
30 MINUTE ONE ON ONE
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT
THAT HE TALKED TO ANYBODY ELSE
AT THE TABLE THE WHOLE NIGHT. SO
THESE ARE JUST SMALL MEMORIES OF
A GREAT MAN AND HIS GREAT HEART.
IT'S GREAT FRIENDSHIP. UH, WITH
ME, THAT'S REALLY UM, JUST AN
EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF
FRIENDSHIPS HE MAINTAINED
THROUGH HIS ENTIRE LIFE. IN OUR
COMMUNITY WILL MISS HIM DEARLY.
WE ALREADY DO MISS HIM DEARLY.
UM AND, UH. I'D BE HONORED TO
HAVE THE SENATE ADJOURNED TODAY
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR CORKY'S CORTEZ.
SENATOR EDMUND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND LARRY REUS DOLLAR UM
LARRY DIED DECEMBER 27TH 2023
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO. HE WAS
BORN IN SAN FRANCISCO. APRIL 3RD
1948 TO HIS PARENTS. THE ROOST
DOLLARS. HIS FATHER, DR BRUCE
TELLER WAS A LOCAL STOCKTON,
PEDIATRICIAN AND MOST EVERY KID
WHO WAS GROWING UP DURING A
CERTAIN TIME IN STOCKTON, NEW
DOCTOR ROOST, DOLLAR AND THE
ROOF. STELLAR BOYS. THERE WERE
FIVE OF THEM. AND THEY WERE ALL
SECURELY EMBEDDED IN THE FABRIC
OF STOCKTON'S SOCIETY. UM LARRY,
GRADUATE FROM STAG HIGH SCHOOL
IN 1966, HE WENT TO CAL BERKELEY
, WHERE HE WAS PART OF THE
MESSAGE UP ZETA SIDE FRATERNITY
WHERE HE WAS THE THRASHER. AURA.
HASHER. I'M NOT SURE FRATERNITY
TALK. UM WHICH CEMENTED MANY OF
HIS LIFETIME RELATIONSHIPS, AND,
UH, ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES
POINTED OUT TO ME THAT THERE
WERE FOUR PEOPLE IN HIS
FRATERNITY AT THAT TIME COMING
OUT OF BERKELEY, WHO ALL WENT
INTO ELECTED OFFICE. UH MIRAGE,
DANILO, BEING ONE OF THEM WHO
SERVED WITH LARRY ROOST OLDER
AND THERE ARE 22 OTHER LOCAL
FOLKS AROUND WHO ALSO SERVED IN
ELECTED OFFICE. LARRY WAS A
RESTAURANTEUR AND AFTER THE
VIETNAM WAR, HE STARTED HIS
CAREER. HE WAS DOWN AT TOM LAMBS
LIGHTHOUSE AND, UH, VALLEY HIGH
IN SAN DIEGO. CAME BACK UP TO
THE BAY AREA WHERE HE WAS THE
MANAGER OF THE SQUARE RIGGER
RIGGER IN ORINDA AND THE SEA OF
CORTEZ ON PIER 39. HE MOVED BACK
INTO THE STOCKTON AREA IN 1981
AND OPENED SOMETHING CALLED THE
OLDER MARKET, WHICH FOR DECADES
IN STOCK AND WAS THE PLACE TO GO
WAS THE PLACE. THE PRESIDENT'S
EIGHT THE SENATORS EIGHT WHEN
EVERYBODY SOMEBODY CAME INTO
TOWN. THEY WENT TO THE OLDER
MARKET, AND LARRY WAS UH,
GREGARIOUS, THE CONSUMMATE HOST
AND COOK, UM AND REALLY WAS
QUITE AN ENTERTAINER. HE RAN FOR
STOCKTON CITY COUNCIL IN 2006.
AFTER THAT, HE SERVED TWO TERMS
ON UM MCKEEN COUNTY'S BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, HELPING THEM TURN
AROUND. OUR OUR LOCAL HOSPITAL.
THERE HE WAS, UM, WHERE SOMEONE
LIKE ME AN INCREDIBLE MENTOR AND
TEACHER WHEN I FIRST GOT INTO
PUBLIC OFFICE, AND I THINK ONE
OF THE KEYS ON MY ABILITY TO
WORK IN A BIPARTISAN
RELATIONSHIP ACROSS THE AISLE TO
REALLY FIGURE OUT HOW WE SOLVE
PROBLEMS. LARRY WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN UH, MUCH TO THE CHAGRIN OF
MANY. MAKING SURE WE DIDN'T GET
OUR PLUMBING REROUTED IN THE
DELTA WITH TWO MASSIVE TUNNELS
AND HE WAS INCREDIBLY ACTIVE AND
RESTORE THE DELTA AND THE DELTA
CONSERVANCY AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
UH AND HE ONCE SAID, TRYING TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THE STATE ON
DELTA ISSUES IS LIKE WHERE AND
PLAYING TIC TAC TOE WEARING
MITTENS IN THE DARK. UM, HE HAD
A WAY OF SPINNING AROUND WORDS.
HE TOOK HIS AND I WAS ALSO THE
BENEFICIARY HAVE DRAGGING ME
AROUND TO EVERY LITTLE SMALL
DELTA TOWN GOING TO COMMUNITY
MEETINGS UP AND DOWN, UP AND
DOWN THE VALLEY AND REALLY
LEARNING. UM HOW TO BE ONE OF
OUR I TALKED TO ONE OF OUR
FRIENDS THIS MORNING BEFORE I
WAS GOING TO DO THIS, AND I SAID
A STORY ABOUT LARRY AND HE, HE
SAID, YOU KNOW WHO SERVED 16
YEARS WITHOUT HAVING ONE ENEMY
LIKE I ALWAYS TOLD RUSTAVI
NEEDED TO PICK MORE FIGHTS. AND
HE SAID TO CLEM, YOU SHOULD PICK
FEWER. IT'S LIKE TOUCHE. THAT'S
JUST THE KIND OF GUY LARRY WAS.
HE WAS ALWAYS LOOKING FOR A WAY
TO BRIDGE TO GET ALONG. AND I
WILL FOREVER BE GRATEFUL FOR HIM
FOR HIS MENTORSHIP AND LEFT THE
STOCKTON COMMUNITY JUST KIND OF
REELING FROM HIS UNTIMELY DEATH.
UH AND WE WILL AND PEOPLE KNOW
THE NAME ROOST DOLLAR SO HIS
GREAT GRANDFATHER WAS FRANK
BRUCE DOLLAR CAPTAIN FRANK, WHO
WAS THE ORIGINAL PERSON ON ON
RUE STELLAR BREWING. WHEN THE
ROOST DOLLAR BEER CAME BACK TO
LIFE A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, THEY
HAD NO IDEA THERE WERE STILL
ROOST EHLERS ALIVE AND QUICKLY
ADOPTED THE FAMILY INTO THEIR
VERY SUCCESSFUL ENDEAVOR. SO FOR
A LOT OF REASONS WE WILL MISS
LARRY ROOST ARE BUT I ASKED TO
SEND IT TO A JOURNEY IN HIS
MEMORY TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT SENATOR EDMUND
FOLLOWING SESSION IF MEMBERS
COULD BRING THEIR PAPERWORK UP
SO WE CAN DO WE HONOR THOSE THAT
RECEIVED TRIBUTES TODAY. I'D
APPRECIATE THAT, UH, SENATOR
ATKINS WITH NO OTHER BUSINESS.
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU, MR
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES ARE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
THURSDAY. JANUARY 18TH 2024 AT 9
A.M. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 330 PM, AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE, AND WE WILL RECONVENE
THURSDAY AT 9 A.M. THANK YOU
MEMBERS.